[Music]
so it was actually a promise that if you
stick with me
right if you hold on to me the
experience you have right now if you
walk that out
now unto him who's able to what keeps
you from falling from the love of god
the bible says constrains me it keeps me
why do you not treat on your wife why
don't you go break into a store and
start still it's the love of god that
keeps me from doing
does god's love have a limit find out on
this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live we got another
exciting topic for you today
does god's love really have a limit
that's one of life's biggest questions i
think and we got london here with an
awesome presentation he's going to walk
us through that but first i want to know
if people want to know how they can
look more into this subject for
resources
uh outside just this show you got some
resources right how can they find that
we do we do
so uh ten talents is
based on the the idea of training
ambassadors for christ and so we want to
give resources for anyone and everyone
who really wants to be able to share
their faith effectively and not in
awkward pushy ways and so one of the
ways you can do that you can go to our
website you can find
resources there
also we have a website 10 times
wiser.com and there we have on-demand
classes and so uh we have classes on
cooking we have classes on prayer we
have classes on how to lose weight
whatever people are needing we're
providing this resource and for your
audience
we're going to do a special offer
because we know you guys uh want to
support uh what they're doing and so
we're going to give you
off
of the classes that i teach so if you uh
go to uh www.tentimeswiser.com
and you put in uh the the code led
five zero you'll get fifty percent off
of the content uh on our site and so we
just want to make that resource
available also
there's another resource uh if you take
out your phone and you go to your app or
you go and you can download this app
it's called american christian
ministries and there's over 7
500 classes sermons and
seminars that are absolutely free and
they're phenomenal if you love what
you're learning here you'll love the app
praise the lord so we live in the
technology information age use your time
wisely people ask all the time what can
i watch well here's something you can
watch right run learn and
and use it to expand the kingdom right
so let's see where we've been so far if
your first time tuning in uh we have
been looking at uh the faith of jesus
and we've looked at the difference
between faith of jesus and faith in
jesus and we started with man's problem
and man's problem is man is
self-centered right and now we realize
that we need to be god
centered god is the one that has the
remedy we looked at the three angels
message specifically the part where it
says that uh here are they that keep the
commandments of god and have the faith
of jesus and so here we see keeping the
commandments of god is connected to the
faith of jesus and so we've also looked
at the important and the challenge to
the church is ephesians says there's
going to be what one body one spirit one
hope one lord one faith one baptism one
god and father one church and that
church is going to have the faith of
jesus they have the remedy for the
world's problems and so we need to find
out how do we find this church what does
this church look like and so this is the
purpose of our study studying the life
and teachings of jesus christ and so we
looked at the challenge we've looked at
the churches fragmented the churches has
really not lived up to the hype that we
claim to be able to solve these
solutions and so today in this session
we're going to look at jesus's love for
man you see love is the answer and so
i'm super excited to share this with you
this is one of my favorite topics is the
love of jesus for man and so
if i were to ask you what's the most
famous scripture in the bible what is it
john 3 16 john 3 16. can anybody tell me
what john 3 17 says
when he sent his son not into the world
to condemn the world
but
so for god so love the world so notice
it says for god so what love the world
notice if you're in this world you are
the object of god's love right and so
regardless of your background your
social economic status whatever you have
or don't have that does not change god's
love for you and so the same love that
caused the father to give his son
caused jesus to give himself
that's right so jesus he says if you've
seen me you've seen the father so notice
what ephesians chapter 5 verse 25 says
husbands what love love your wives how
even even as christ loved the church and
what
gave himself for it so notice god is the
the giver of love notice of galatians
chapter 2 verse 20 it says i am
crucified with christ nevertheless
i live but what not i but christ lives
in me and the life which i now live in
the flesh how does he live it
by the faith of the son oh no he doesn't
say by faith in jesus
but paul says i'm literally living by
his faith wow right and so the faith of
son of god who loved me and what did he
do he gave he gave so notice the faith
of jesus is to give himself for others
so the church should model
their evangel living their outreach
their in-reach on giving
right but oftentimes people come to
church to get something right they come
to jesus to get something like he's some
genie in the bottle that they can get
something but no jesus says come and
give yourself to serve to serve right so
why is this important why should i give
my heart my life you might be asking
that okay i've heard this my whole life
or i'm just coming into this christian
thing why should i give up the world why
should i give up my movies and my music
and my whatever it is why
you see why did he give himself
you see oftentimes we're focusing on
what
it's on me that's humanism right but we
need to focus on what is it that
motivated god to give himself love love
just love you
because that's the pat answer everybody
knows god is love he just but what else
motivated him
how did that love
live itself out practically well i think
i mean he is our creator
and i i mean kind of like hey he created
this amazing
being or
creature
and then he's all this craziness you
know sin and caming everything it's like
i love you so much i want you to come
back to this amazing
i want to spend time with you and all
this stuff so i think that's why when we
have a relationship with you know i got
two two girls you know and
that relationship with my daughters it's
like man i i want to hang out with you
you know i'm saying like when or any
relationship you know when that that
relationship is broken
it's like you feel like i cannot do
anything to hang out with this person or
when that person no longer wants to hang
out with you
that's painful when you are there to
give the love but they
they reject your love the bible says in
john it says he came to his own but his
own received him not right so notice
revelation chapter 1 verse 5 it says and
unto him that what
love it so why did he
give himself we're trying to answer that
question unto him who loved us and what
washed up washed us when you wash what
what does that mean you're trying to
clean it up that means you're dirty
right
so not only did he love us but he knew
that in our sin
he could not have the type of
relationship that he wanted to have and
so his giving was not only just because
he loved us but because he wants to wash
us from what
from our sins from our sins and how did
he do it
in his own blood
so he loved us he washed us in his own
blood and what does he want to do notice
galatians 1 verse 4. would you read this
for us alex sure who gave himself
uh for our sins ah so now it's focusing
why did he give himself
for our sins isaiah 59 verse 2 says your
sins have separated you from your god so
because he loves us he says i want to
remove the thing that what separates you
from me and we're like little kids no no
no i want it i always do this example so
so the bible says that you shall call
his name jesus and he shall save his
people in their sins amen
no see
it says he will save us what from sin
and then it says uh that it says behold
the lamb of god that does what takes
away
why does he want to take away the scene
so we can because it's
because it separates okay will you take
my iphone please that's iphone be very
careful okay all right go ahead
why can't you take it because you're
gripping too tightly okay okay okay let
me hold on let me go over here come on
mikey i'll save you brother oh there you
go what
so what what what was the difference
brittany
well first of all i was playing tug of
war with you
and you just handed it straight to him
you let him take it i let him take it i
don't think there was i didn't see any
resistance exactly okay so what's the
illustration illustrate to us about a
relationship with god
you have to be willing to give
and and surrender surrender right so my
question is
am i holding on to sin or is sin holding
on to me wherever you are
what do you think
are you holding on to sin because if i'm
holding on to sin
i can put it down anytime i want to but
if sin is holding on to me i need a
deliverer mm-hmm
you're yourself i can't do it myself you
need a savior right and so paul says oh
what a wretched man that i am who will
what
deliver me
so jesus came not only to show us love
he came to deliver us from this body the
bible says of death wow right that's why
christianity right now and say hey i
love you oh yeah everybody i love jesus
they said i want to clean you from your
sense oh no i don't like that part of
jesus to be the tron of my life right i
want you just to love and praise the
lord
yeah right so so there's a difference
between jesus being lord
right and savior that's right so what
we're going to dive into is we're going
to see why did he give and how did he
how does he save us right kind of like
the lane i like the lane right i like
the lane but i don't like the the the
lion come on now all right so notice
that he might deliver us from the
present what
evil world according to the will of of
god and our father so jesus came to
deliver us from sin right he came to
save us from this present evil is the
world presently evil oh yes right so it
was not duty but love that compelled
jesus to come to our world to save
mankind so the bible says what god is
love
romans chapter 5 verse 8 says while we
were what yes
sinners yet sinners christ died for the
righteous
is that what he said
for us yes it says it died for the
ungodly but oftentimes the message that
we communicate to the people out there
is that you have to be clean you have to
be perfect you have to be spotless and
then you can come to jesus
but jesus is going to show us today how
to really connect with people see the
bible says the message in revelation
goes to every nation kindred tongue and
people does that mean rich people yeah
that means poor
that means male 1 that means female that
means the good
but what about the bad yes how does god
treat the rebellious the wicked the ones
that thumb their nose and
god how does he deal with that it says
what but god what commended his love
toward us that what no why we were yet
still incense so mikey when you were out
there
and you were still rebellious and
god's love did not change
you are and was and will always be his
priority i think of the prodigal son
story come on are you going to talk
about that no go ahead so the father
loved his son his son willfully said
father give me my things i want to go
and the father loving his son gave him
the free will to leave he could have
held on to him no you're not going to go
and that
son would have hated his father but
when
he saw that the world had nothing to
offer him he came back to the father and
the father was like rejoicing right yes
i love you i'm a party here's a jacket
and we're going to throw a party right
he never stopped loving his son his son
walked away so jesus knows the value of
the human soul
so let's learn from his life
what man's life is worth not to other
men but to god so we're going to look at
two case studies one we're going to look
at lessons from gadara and two we're
going to look at the woman caught in
adultery so matthew chapter five if you
are at home and you have your bible get
your bible this is important because we
want you to see it for yourself mark
chapter five verse one through five so
brittany would you read for us please
and they came over onto the other side
of the sea into the country of gadarenes
and when he was come out of the ship
immediately there met him out of the
tombs a man with an unclean spirit so
what's the picture jesus is coming the
disciples are there he gets out of the
boat and immediately there comes a man
out of the what
the graveyard
and the man is full of what
unclean
here's the idea jesus is coming
and this man comes
rushing to jesus
and jesus is there
and this man
was twisted and mangled he was demented
right and so notice what it says in
verse three who had his dwelling among
the two so he wasn't just hanging out
there
he was living amongst the dead right so
it shows you his spiritual condition you
can't get worse
than living in a cemetery right it says
that no man could what
bind him no not with change so they had
tried to tame this do they had tried to
to control him but he was so out of
control he was so full of evil and
wickedness that no man could what tame
him because he had been often bound with
what
fetters and chains
and the chains he had plucked asunder by
so they would chain him and he was just
like
right it says and the fetter's broken in
pieces neither could any man what tame
him now when you think of taming
something you don't think of taming a
man do you what do you think of when you
think of it right you tame a beast
so what is the the author telling us
this man was considered to be
inhumane
he wasn't even human anymore they tried
to to bound him but
notice he broke the fetters right it
says and always notice night and day he
was in the mountains and in the tombs
what was he doing crowning crying
are people cutting themselves today yeah
sure is humanity crying out today
and what did he cut himself with stones
right
so he was
the worst of the worst right so from
external indicators this man was totally
what hopeless right so i've been in that
situation right where i was considered
totally hopeless right and i've seen
other people who look like they were
totally hopeless like oh man they've
gone too far
but
notice he was demon-possessed
he was morally corrupted he was
physically in bondage he was mentally
deranged no man could tame him they saw
him as a beast
he was crazy
you know everybody's got a crazy uncle
right right
uncle joe or uncle bobby oh yeah a
little bit crazy yeah so so and that's
part of cancel culture too right if they
call you crazy that's automatically oh
he's crazy
right and so notice this question
did jesus agree
with this diagnosis no
how do we know because he went right up
to him he went right up to him so we're
looking at jesus's love for man right
so the disciples ran away
they were like ah
and jesus he confronted this man so
let's look at the context of the story
because we we're going to see something
really powerful about the love of god so
remember they were on their way there
and they ran into what
a raging storm
right and what was jesus doing during
the storm sleeping so their lives were
in peril
what did they do they cried out to jesus
and notice mark 4 verse 39 and he rose
now why could jesus be at such perfect
peace in the middle of a storm
yeah he was real close with the father
it says he rebuked the wind and said
unto the sea what
peace be still
and the wind ceased
and there was what great calm we're
gonna see this happens not only in
nature but in human nature
right there's a storm of emotion there's
a storm of anger and bitterness and
hatred someone was molested someone was
abused someone and there's this this
raging storm right and we feed it with
media or we speed it with music or
relationships or sex or whatever it is
and only one man can say
peace be still and that man is the man
christ jesus amen so he did what he
rebuked the wind right he said peace be
still
the wind ceased there was a great calm
so notice peace be still
so why all this trouble why would jesus
go through all of this trouble to get to
this place called gadara
to uh to save that man just 100 you see
he took all this effort he left where he
was at
and he went all the way over and who do
you think did not want him to go there
right the devil the bible says we
wrestle not against flesh and blood but
against principalities and powers and
evil so the the storm
was sent by the devil to present prevent
jesus from getting to this demoniac so
when we're in the ministry or something
like to try to save people's lives and
you see all this craziness you say why
does it happen to me because let me tell
you you're doing the right thing because
later on you're going to be savings
right right so go ahead yeah that's
interesting because um like jesus could
have been like oh man this storm is real
bad you know i'll just pray for him
and keep him he could have just turned
around or something you know but he
actually continued to pursue despite
everything that was in his way to stop
them from getting there so what if the
church was like that
what if every church member would go out
of their way just to help one person
change the world it would change the
world that's the power so notice could
the disciples change save themselves wow
they were they were professional
fishermen they had been in store but
this storm was satanic and they ran and
they cried to jesus
now we're gonna see this happens again
so jesus took all this trouble because
this man needed help right so he was in
slavery to sin notice what isaiah
chapter 61 verse 1 says it says the
spirit of the lord god is upon me
it says
the what was on him
so if the church is going to be
effective in its ministry in saving
demoniacs it needs what
spirit the spirit of the lord to be
upon me upon you upon all of us right so
notice because the lord has what
anointed me to
preach oh wait that's not my job that's
the pastor job right
come on man i'm not a preacher but the
bible says
that we're to preach to every nation and
that word preach means to proclaim
now that doesn't necessarily mean we
have to use words right
there's a there's a bumper sticker who
said preach the gospel if necessary use
words actually this generation is tired
of our words
they say in the streets talk is cheap
cheap right we make a great profession
but then our expression
there's no power in it so jesus
this prophecy says he has anointed me to
preach what good tidings unto the meek
it says it goes on he has sent me to
bind up the what brokenhearted are we
living in a generation of people who are
brokenhearted right and to proclaim at
liberty those who are what
captives are people who are captivated
by the things of this world oh yeah
notice so and it says and the opening of
the prison are there people in the
prison house of sin yeah
that they that are bound so this man
needed help from jesus
so notice isaiah 62 says to proclaim the
acceptable year the lord and it says and
the vengeance the what
vengeance the vengeance of our god what
do you think god makes god upset
sin sin
he says god is going to take vengeance
on sin sin is an intruder
sin is that which separates god from
that which he love he says you're the
apple of my eye
and so he's going to destroy sin and
everything connected to sin
so notice
uh it says to comfort all that what
more with all the death because of this
pandemic
do we need comfort yeah absolutely right
it says uh question what was the result
of jesus's mission so he did all of this
what was the result of jesus's mission
would you like to know
yes okay mark chapter 5 verse 7. and
this is the demoniac and he cried
with a what type of voice
a loud voice
and moses says what have i to do with
the jesus the what the son of the most
high god who's speaking here
the demons the demons and it says i
adjure thee by god that thou tore maybe
not is it possible that the demons
believe more than we do
oh yeah uh fallen angels they know who
is there they know he says have you come
to what so the very presence of jesus
torments the wicked
torments the the demons right
when i was outside in the church and
i didn't want to hear christian music
i mean seriously
every time when i was going to you know
those afternoons i don't have to pass
that study room
and it was bibles and everything and i
just i just i hated going through it
right because i knew what it was right
i knew that that over here it was
telling me
where are you going
you're doing the right you know you're
doing wrong and everything like and they
was telling me like you're wrong you
know go back to the and i didn't want to
go through that right and
it's
human nature it's tormented i don't want
to hear that kind of stuff because you
you know
so here we have this this is the setting
the background right so verse 8 says for
he said unto him come out of the man
thou unclean spirit and he asked him
what is your name
and he answered and saying what my name
is eugene for we
are many now if you look up it says
we are me so i looked up a legion a
roman legion was anywhere from 3 000 to
5.5
thousand demons were living in this man
how does that even how is that possible
spiritual things are spiritually just
discerned i have no clue but notice wow
this man was so like think about it
wicked wicked i mean your thoughts you
your action your
anything every thought and imagination
of his heart was only evil continually
cutting
crying right in the graveyard so it says
and he besought him much that he would
not send them away out of the country so
notice this is amazing now this is a
really important point so notice what is
the deem where the demons ask
they see a herd of pigs right
and they ask jesus
now what does this teach
who's all-powerful
god if the demon has to ask permission
to go into
the herd of swine who's the one who
gives the authority jesus jesus says all
power
all authority
in heaven and on earth is delivered unto
me so church therefore what
and we say oh i don't know if i can do
it that's not my gift he's like it's not
about you yeah
it's not about me he says i have all
power
right and that's what the world is
waiting to see and experience the power
of god so notice this it says so they go
he gives them permission
5 000 run off into the ocean they drown
they die
notice what verse 14 says and they that
fed the swine and told and told it to
the city and in the country and they
went out to see what was done so
the one who was guarding the the the
swine what they do they ran and gave
their testimony
so i have a question uh
and the bible said it was five thousand
pigs
i think so if i'm not mistaken i have to
look it up no i'm just saying because i
remember you were saying that when uh
when this person was saying you know uh
what is your name and everything he said
religions right and you find out that it
was like 3 000 to
five thousand so it's kind of
interesting that
all those five thousand demons he was
inside it was like five thousand pigs
you know that's like kind of gives you
the number of how many he had yeah right
so
uh so notice the people come so he goes
and gives his testimony
come see you lost so now what were pigs
what were herds what were cattle back
then it was money yeah this was industry
right so
notice this question what did the people
see when they got to jesus
when they came to jesus what did they
see what happened to this demoniac
transformation a total transformation
verse 15 says and they came to jesus and
see him that was past tense possessed
with the devil and had the legion
sitting
clothed and in his right mind and they
were afraid
ecstatic
they were excited it says no they were
afraid
so think about this man that used to
torment them this man that was cutting
himself in he was delivered from all
these demons and the people were afraid
the people were not happy about this
delivery have you ever seen that in the
church
people come in and they're excited and
they've been delivered and people were
like
like what are you doing here a little
extreme right so notice question
what did the people do next
they got upset right they got upset
killed all my pigs
you you cut off my my financial
stability and they began to pray him
jesus to depart from their so they said
you know uh uh you got to get out of
here jesus wow like jesus does a bona
fide miracle
and saves one of their own and they're
like you got to get out of here
so why
what's the lesson
what is god trying to teach us
about his value of man
his worth of the human soul and how we
value or
better yet undervalued that guy wasn't
even worth
pigs come on to them they we that was 5
000 pigs we you know but jesus saw this
guy as a person he needs to be set free
and they should have been excited
see jesus had crossed the lake to
illustrate the fact that no man however
degraded
is to be passed by wow is that kind of
like the same thing about the jews
i mean they want to have this superhero
guide to deliver from roman right army
and just say no i come over here to save
you from your sins well that's the jews
what about us you know we always want to
talk about everybody else yeah
you heard about the pastor who uh came
to a new congregation
and uh they were waiting for him to
preach and he actually dressed up like a
bum outside
of the church
and all the parishioners passed the bomb
and no one and then it comes time for
for the sermon and the bomb
the homeless man walks down yeah and
everybody's like and everybody's like
what in the world and he walks up to the
pulpit and he's the pastor and he takes
off he says i want to know how much work
we had to do
wow
and so often times we devalue the soul
when jesus came to save every single
person what's another lesson as long as
there is life there is what
there is hope jesus was and is hope for
the hopeless what worth jesus places on
just one man so question what's up with
the 2000
swine
what's up with this wine like why does
jesus not like pigs i mean i know it's
unclean but what's up with that no why
did jesus
allow this demonstration of this
destruction of the swine maybe to reveal
man's heart
so notice let's say that they were worth
50 000
in today's economy right so that
community just lost 50 000
see jesus allowed them to die to show
the value god placed on one soul and the
costs he himself would pay for
one soul's deliverance you ever heard
the quote says if there was only one
soul
jesus would have come and died for that
how much value does god place on one
soul
so
his own people rejected him
you see oftentimes people get hurt by
christians yeah people get hurt by
people who profess to love them right
and
jesus is saying no no
my faith my life my teaching is to love
that which the world says is unlovable
so they might have been happy for the
man you think they were happy that he
wasn't going to torment them anymore
they could actually walk in the
mountains without being
chased away
but notice but at what price was his
freedom purchased
fifty thousand dollars
see oftentimes i've done evangelistic
series right and they've spent all this
money
and if the baptisms aren't what no great
significant oh wow oh we spent all this
time and effort in and only three souls
got oh what a failure
can you can you imagine that god is
saying what
i would have done it for one i would
have done it for one
and you say three is a failure
you see how the church
he says let this mind be in you that was
also in christ jesus right
so notice was the cost of this hopeless
man's salvation worth two thousand swine
in the people's mind no no on their mind
no absolutely not so notice
mark chapter eight verse 36
it says for what shall it profit of man
if he show what
gain the whole world and lose his own
soul i believe we're living in a
generation that is focused on gaining
the world
and the things of this world
and and we have lost the value of one
human soul
and the faith of jesus is gonna bring us
back to really valuing what god values
see god doesn't care about our churches
he doesn't care about our our camps he
doesn't care about our buildings he
cares about souls amen
so
verse 37 or what shall a man give in
what exchange in exchange for his own
soul now in the bible
who exchanged something for his his his
own soul his own heritage his own
birthright yeah
jacob jacob no it was esau
he saw what did he sell his birthright
for
a pot of beans beans
so what does that represent instant
gratification
right
instant so we have a generation that
instagram right insta pot
you know so all of it centered on self
that's where this humanistic idea and it
seeped into the church where we're so
self-centered that we can literally walk
by people who we know are lost
we know they're not in a saving
relationship with god and we say well
that's not my gift
that's not my calling i always ask
people what's your gift and what's your
calling what are you doing with it
and so
jesus is teaching us
you know what life is cheap in the eyes
of man
right
life is cheap
but
we have to ask ourselves are they worth
it
is it worth going out of your comfort
zone
to talk to someone who you know is in
sin who doesn't have a personal
relationship
it is worth it it is worth it man right
so you think about this generation you
think of this this generation that is is
saturated in pain jesus went out of his
way to save mankind jesus left heaven to
show how much value god places on some
human
no all mankind right so as we look at
the life of jesus
it invigorates us to say man if i want
to be a true christian which means to be
christ-like what does that mean for me
how do i live my life
i have to live it to serve other i have
a friend and uh he pastors a church and
their motto is live to bless others
imagine the church lived to bless others
and not ourselves so jesus died for
others he paid the ultimate price to set
man free from sins bounds this is the
mission of the church so most of us
don't think twice when we see people
right we go on with our life with our
it's all about us right so i have a
question
if you have you have you all have
children right
you sent your child you gave and my
children they went to the beach and i
said hey i'm going to take care of them
we got this we got that and here i am me
and my wife we're sitting on the
lifeguard
right and we have said we will take care
of your child you've invested 15 16 17
years of effort and energy and we go and
we see your child drowning
and we're there
and we don't do anything
to save her
and we come home
and we say hey man this is what happened
i'm sorry and you said well what what
could you have done i said well we saw
her drowning but you know it was an
inconvenience you know i'm not a
lifeguard it's not my gift
how would you feel towards me and my
family
would you not be indignant
how do you think god feels when
his children
right the church says i'm gonna take
responsibility
and we see people drowning in sin
so what do you think about um
just the whole idea of why god
or why it seems like he relies on us
rather than intervening himself
so what do you all think why does god
subject himself to
man being involved
because he could just reveal himself and
save right but why doesn't he
you know i think about like how
how much i love seeing my daughter grow
and and like see her create and i love
like watching watching her make things
out of clay and draw and stuff and you
know i could just pick up a pen and draw
myself but i like watching her do it it
brings us some kind of joy
and it's helping her actually so
maybe he's working through us to help
ourselves grow
so there was a story about a
a man who was walking in the winter and
he was about to die it was snow he was
lost
and he was literally could feel the
blood
becoming ice in his veins right and he
was just like oh and then he stumbled
upon a man who was in a worse condition
than he was
he was covered in snow and he picked
that man up
and he used all his energy to get that
man to safety and guess what in saving
that man he was actually saving himself
so in helping others who are we really
helping
ourselves to to explain what you mean by
that it was
if the man would have continued he would
have died but the warmth of the other
yes kept him alive right ago yeah so do
you see god could do it himself but in
actually
employing man in this plan of salvation
it actually develops our character
because god is love and so love is other
centered and so when i
when i love someone else and go out for
someone else then guess what i become to
become like christ who is unselfish
right so how do you be so how do you um
i guess separate that from selfishness
because there is a benefit to helping
someone else and you save yourself
versus
like just a genuine intention i think
who gets the glory
so if i'm doing it for my own glory
that's wicked
but if i'm doing it for his glory right
then that's righteous if you're taking a
picture of yourself giving rise man
exactly right jesus said let let no man
see he said don't do your arms to be
seen of men go in your closet
and the father who sees you in secret
secret will reward you
openly right so these are the the
teachings of jesus so notice luke
chapter 8 verse 38 it says now the man
out of whom the devils were departed
besought him that he might be with him
but jesus sent him away saying
return unto your what oh so
how long had this man been with jesus
just like a couple minutes brother right
and this man
now becomes an evangelist mm-hmm
and where did he start his evangelistic
campaign at his own home at his own home
he says and and show how great things
god has done unto you he says and he
went his way and what did he do he
published throughout what the whole city
so the very city that sent jesus away
you think they was going to reject him
oh yeah oh no because this was the man
who used to torment them
right yeah and so now he you think they
would listen to him
you think he had a testimony right yeah
they've seen the change what we learned
is and i learned in japan
that
the the japanese would are much more
effective at reaching japanese
the the mexicans are much more effective
at reaching other mexicans right because
the culture because they understand the
language and the nuances so jesus says i
want you to go back and tell them what
god has done for you wow they overcame
by the what where they're testing the
blood of the lamb and the word their
testimony so now he goes and gives his
testimony he says go home
right so one more case study so what did
you learn from this first case study
just one one jewel that you would like
to to share with the audience what's
something that we can take from this
the
god thinks of us as infinitely valuable
like worthy of dying for and that
he wants us to see people the same way
he sees people wow
and also i mean we talk about love right
and
what amazing love i mean you know what
amazing love that he can
he can do anything even that much to his
own life and he said you know what i'm
going to go with that and save that
person right you know and it's like i
don't really care if i just
give my life right this person right and
and no matter what the barriers or the
boundaries or the or the obstacles
nothing was going to stop jesus from
getting to godard yeah for the rich poor
right i mean you got this in your head
or i mean anything you know whatever you
is outside right he said you know what i
really care about why you
look whatever i just i see a person and
i need you i want your heart you know i
see my child that's right i see the one
i created yeah right so john 8 verses 3
through 11 we know the story the woman
caught in adultery now this woman was
caught in adultery she was brought to
jesus and they threw her at jesus feet
john 8 verse 4 says
they say unto him master this woman was
taken in adultery in the very what
have you ever been caught red-handed so
to speak in the very act
so they caught this woman in the very
act it says now notice their question
they're testing jesus's theology now
moses and the law commanded us that such
should be stoned but what sayest thou
come on jesus you're a rabbi
the law says this but what are you gonna
say they're trying to entrap him right
what
was that the truth did the law really
say that the woman
caught in adultery should be stoned i
think it's both parties right ah
so it was actually the woman and the man
so they were fraudulent from the
beginning
and jesus knowing the word of god right
so notice what leviticus says it says
the adulterer and the adulteress shall
be put to death so was she guilty yes
yes
by the law was she to die yes yes
in the eyes of these men was she
worthless yeah yeah yes so see
man
continually has this devaluation
of other men and women right so
again
from a human point of view life is cheap
right and you might be thinking that you
are worthless you might be thinking that
you have no value but the point of our
study is that you have value that god
loves you and you are worth his death
life and resurrection and he's coming
back for you because he loves you
question
did jesus agree that she was worthless
no no
so notice jesus it says
he that is without sin among you let him
what that's the first time
now he's speaking to the church
right
so when these outcasts when these
undesirables when these sketchy people
right come in
he says he that is without sin let him
what cast the first stone what did jesus
do how did he treat her
he he lifts her up and woman he says
what where are those that accuse you and
she says what
no
man
condemns me
now who's the only man who rightly could
have condemned her
jesus jesus right he says
she says no man lord neither do i can
you imagine if you were that woman
yeah knowing you're
knowing you're guilty and jesus the only
man in the universe that had
righteous
right and justly could condemn you he
says neither do i conde what do you
think that did to that woman
you think she was like oh
yeah
so this is the love
that transforms the human heart amen i
think it's amazing that no one could
have probably told her from that point
on who she was right because she got her
identity from christ that's what he said
about her her identity was not in a
church it wasn't a family it wasn't her
identity was in her faith
in jesus but it's really his faith in
her
he said what
okay
go and what
how could he say he knows she's a sinner
he knows she's prone to this sexual
immorality and he out of his mouth said
was that a command or a promise
a command i would say
or was it a promise
so did she have it in herself not to sin
no no no so it was actually a promise
that if you stick with me
right if you hold on to me the
experience you have right now if you
walk that out
now unto him who's able to what keeps
you from falling from the love of god
the bible says constrains me it keeps me
why do you not treat on your wife why
don't you go break into a store and
start stealing it's the love of god that
keeps me from doing so when it comes to
standards when it comes to the external
things the only thing that's going to
motivate somebody to do those things is
the love of god
that's true but what we try to do is we
try to put the standards before the love
yeah the cart before the horse right so
notice
they were all sinners true or false true
true right
in the eyes of these religious men she
was worthy of only one thing and that
was death is that you
i've been there
i've been there where i felt worthless i
i felt dirty and and filthy and and at
that moment at my lowest point that's
when god reached out to me wow you see
the law you know what the word law
stands for what's the how you spell it l
love a
at
w work
love it works so the law of god is
really the love of god at work in my
heart you see
the wages of what sin is death
if we left it there man
right the wages of sin is death
here the words of jesus neither do i can
but
the gift of god
is eternal life how
through christ jesus right so but the
gift of god i want you to look at the
images here it's the lamb
right
that was slain
the gift of god
right
is eternal life
so through jesus christ our lord through
his grace he can say go and sin no more
in the eyes of men she had no value but
in the eyes of jesus her life was worth
saving for his kingdom
is made up of what redeemed sinners the
son of man
is come to seek and save that which are
found
perfect
spotless
that which is what
lost so what are the results
case study number two the demoniac he
said to go home
what results jesus comes back and guess
what the whole town it says in luke 8 41
it says jesus was returned and the
people what gladly the same people told
jesus to leave
when they came when he came back they
were like jesus
and it says they were away one man's
testimony wow
changed the whole city that valued pigs
over people powerful wow jesus placed
confidence in this man to be a witness
for him so it shows us that that no man
is unfit to be a witness
to the grace of god let's look at the
last case study the adulteress right
remember
jesus is with simon
right simon he's the one who uh had been
healed and she comes in and notices and
behold a woman of the city which was a
sinner so how did they look at her she
was a sinner she comes she comes to his
feet she breaks open the alabaster box
and jesus i'm skipping because i want to
get to a point
he asked simon this question he says
uh if one was in debt
and he had a little debt
and he was forgiven a little
and one had a huge debt and he was given
a lot and they were both forgiven who
would love more
the one with the bigger debt
right
right the one who had the worst of the
worst of the worst
and if you look at mary she never left
the side of jesus mary at the tomb mary
at the cross mary at the resurrection
mary was walking with jesus her faith
was not just in jesus she actually had
his faith
so this is the effect of the everlasting
gospel and the faith of jesus this is
the love jesus has for you and for me so
i want to encourage you all
that no matter what you have done how uh
difficult your life has been
that you are the object of god he says
you're the apple of my eye he says i
will give men for you i loved you so
much that i gave my only begotten son
and so
this is the message that the world is
waiting not to hear but to what
to see it land out yeah i mean i see
uh practical christianity thanks so much
for sharing this topic yeah i see why
this is your favorite you know jesus
compares us to his bride he compares
this to his children and i'm thinking
i would give my life for my wife and for
my child there's no way i would ever
if if
if it was me or them i would never watch
them die you know i would gladly give up
my life and it's amazing to think that
the creator of the universe
cares that much about us when we seem so
small and insignificant and we're
sinners and unworthy of his love
honestly
he loves us so much
i know that this was a blessing for me
if it was a blessing for you please like
and share this with your family and
friends if you give us a simple thumbs
up it really helps get this video out in
the algorithm so that more people can be
blessed by this message and that's
exactly what we're talking about here
we're talking about evangel living
evangelizing to the world live this
thing out share this so that other
people can see the gift of god his love
which is eternal life and we just want
to see more and more people get to
experience that love and be in the
kingdom we love you god bless you like
share subscribe we will see you guys
next week on led live
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
you